[Música]
Alemania es ese país que siempre suele
aparecer en los mejores puestos de los
rankings de productividad calidad de
vida y desarrollo humano la mayor
potencia económica es vista por muchos
políticos analistas y expertos de todo
tipo como un auténtico modelo a seguir
sin embargo queridos amigos amigas de
visual politic en los últimos tiempos
son otras las noticias que están
acaparando cada vez más titulares nos
referimos exactamente a cosas como estas
Berlín aumenta la delincuencia en la
capital alemana tras la pandemia la
policía alemana pide zonas libres de
cuchillos en las ciudades mucha
delincuencia muy poco personal el jefe
de policía de bremen da la alarma el
aumento de los robos y los robos de
vehículos es especialmente dramático ya
lo veis por increíble que nos pueda
parecer Lo cierto es que Alemania está
hoy atravesando un fortísimo repunte en
sus cifras de delitos y crímenes
violentos No importa que este tipo de
problemas se suelan asociar a tasas de
de pobreza altas elevados niveles de
marginalidad o falta de cuerpos de
seguridad Alemania uno de los países más
ricos y desarrollados de todo el mundo
no tiene ninguno de esos problemas pero
pese a ello las cifras de criminalidad
se están disparando de repente según los
datos oficiales los datos de la propia
policía el país se enfrenta a una
incipiente ola de robos asesinatos
delitos sexuales y tráfico de personas
en este campo Alemania está
experimentando su peor momento de por lo
menos la última década
[Música]
ahora bien puede que te estés haciendo
una pregunta pero Enrique Alemania de
verdad si yo lo que había escuchado era
precisamente todo lo contrario del
poderoso país tutón pues sabéis que no
me extraña hasta hace No mucho la
situación era totalmente diferente de
hecho tan recientemente como en 2019 la
situación era exactamente la contraria
por aquel tiempo la verdad no tan lejano
Alemania sacaba pecho Alemania registra
la tasa de criminalidad más baja desde
1992 la tasa de criminalidad en Alemania
cae a su nivel más bajo en décadas Pero
entonces Qué explica semejante cambio
qué demonios está pasando con el crimen
en Alemania Qué diantres explica esta
ola de violencia e inseguridad pues
queridos amigos amigas Estas son las
preguntas que nos hemos hecho en visual
politic preguntas que vamos a responder
en este vídeo gasolina y arranquemos
Pero antes solo un segundo eres
consciente de todo lo que te estás
perdiendo por no usar Surf Shark nuestro
patrocinador de hoy lo más importante de
todo la seguridad con Surf Shark tus
movimientos en internet estarán
fuertemente protegidos cifrados y a
salvo de ojos curiosos además con Clean
web se acabarán los anuncios intrusivos
y el malware y eso no es todo con Surf
Shark alert también te enterarás al
instante de si tu información personal
ha sido filtrada pero es que aún hay más
Surf Shark es la primera VPN comercial
con servidores en más de un centenar de
países algo así como una especie de
pasaporte global a golpe de click con el
que vas a poder acceder a contenidos
bloqueados por ubicación interesante
esto eh Y si te preocupa tener que
elegir en Qué dispositivo usarlo
tranquilo con la misma cuenta podrás
proteger todos tus dispositivos ya sea
tu móvil tu tablet el ordenador la tele
o la consola sin límites De hecho si
quieres ahorrar al máximo puedes
compartir la cuenta con tus mejores
amigos o con la familia y así entre
todos pagaré solo unos pocos céntimos al
mes cada uno y lo mejor de todo por ser
parte de la comunidad visual politic
puedes disfrutar de hasta 6 meses extra
totalmente gratis usando el código
politic os dejamos el link en la
descripción y dicho esto Ahora sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
continuemos creo que si hablamos de
historia está claro que Alemania es un
país que da para todo dos guerras
mundiales el muro de Berlín la creación
de la Unión Europea y bueno es que qué
os voy a contar pero amigos hay un
periodo muy importante que en realidad
se suele pasar por alto pero que cambió
Alemania en términos económicos de
arriba a abajo a hablamos de la
reunificación Y es que veréis cuando el
muro de Berlín cayó la parte comunista
de Alemania tuvo que adaptarse de golpe
al capitalismo eso supuso que de la
noche a la mañana Muchas empresas
públicas que eran socialistas tuvieran
que cerrar directamente tras ello el
empleo se disparó aumentaron los niveles
de pobreza en el corto plazo y la
desigualdad entre el este y el oeste
empezó a provocar enormes conflictos
sociales para colmo la policía de la
Alemania Oriental estaba especializada
en el control social la censura y la
represión política Así que tuvo que ser
remodelada de arriba a abajo y no solo a
nivel operativo sino también a nivel
cultural e Cuál fue el resultado de todo
esto pues como os podéis imaginar con
una policía patas arriba y una situación
económica particularmente mala Alemania
desarrolló un entorno perfecto para la
proliferación del crimen por supuesto
con el tiempo la situación Fue mejorando
la liberalización del este impulsó mucho
su economía y al mismo tiempo el
Gobierno Federal la regó de dinero
público a mansalva más tarde esa mejora
se tradujo en una reducción de las tasas
de criminalidad y de esta forma Alemania
mej su nivel de seguridad hasta situarse
prácticamente por encima de otros países
como la misma Francia sin embargo el
repunte de delincuencia del que hablamos
en este vídeo no es el que sucedió tras
la reunificación sino que en este caso
es uno completamente diferente prestad
[Música]
atención aclarando los
números Pero antes de meternos de lleno
en materia Tenemos que tener unas
cuantas cuestiones en cuenta en primer
lugar queridos amigos os hemos hecho una
pequeña trampa sí la criminalidad en
Alemania ha crecido pero seguimos
hablando de un país europeo las cifras
que reporta Berlín en materia de robos u
homicidios son sumamente bajas En
comparación con el resto del mundo
seguimos hablando de un país
razonablemente seguro nada que ver con
los datos de Estados Unidos América
Latina o incluso Canadá por ejemplo
Alemania reporta una tasa de homicidios
de 0,76 personas por cada 100,000
habitantes y eso es muy poco esta cifra
es todo un sueño para otros países como
Estados Unidos que reporta un nivel de
6,81 homicidios por 100,000 habitantes
casi 10 veces más y no hablemos ya de
América Latina cuyo dato en 2021 fue de
19,91 qué salvajada Y aunque en otras
rúbricas criminales las diferencias son
más pequeñas Lo cierto es que Alemania
sigue siendo un país europeo es decir en
lo que a crimen se refiere está años luz
de los países americanos podría eso
cambiar lo
veremos en segundo lugar tenemos que
tener claro el efecto de la pandemia Y
es que veréis su impacto económico
provocó un repunte general de la
criminalidad en todo el mundo ya sabéis
más desempleo más ingresos más
incertidumbre Europa y Alemania no
fueron una excepción si comparamos la
tasa de homicidios entre los años 2019 y
2020 Alemania es el sexto país de la
región donde más aumentaron estos
crímenes basta con echar un vistazo al
ranking para ver cóm los tones tuvieron
una evolución muy similar a la de países
como Malta chipre o Portugal países con
los que Berlín nunca suele compararse
ahora bien el problema no es que los
homicidios se dispararán durante la
pandemia sino que en los años siguientes
Esto no se revirtió y justo aquí es
donde viene la sorpresa mientras que
países como Estonia O lituania sí que
lograron revertir los incrementos de la
delincuencia la caída de la criminalidad
en Alemania en 2021 No Fue suficiente
como para revertir por completo La
escalada reportada durante la pandemia y
luego para colmo en 2022 y 2023 los
datos fueron peores y amigos Esta es
justo la preocupación de las autoridades
A diferencia de sus vecinos el crimen en
el país está empeorando año tras año sin
que exista una causa económica clara que
respalda esta situ aber
sital Pero por qué tanto alarmismo si
los datos parecen razonablemente buenos
pues como os decimos tiene que ver sobre
todo con la evolución con la evolución y
con el hecho de que en el caso alemán
los homicidios no son precisamente los
crímenes que más han crecido en los
últimos años por ejemplo en el caso del
tráfico de personas como podéis ver el
promedio del periodo 20202022 es un 55
por más alto que el reportado en el
periodo 2013-2015 luego otro caso
similar es el de los crímenes sexuales
hasta 2016 venían siendo de unos 7,000
por año pero en 2018 estos rozaron los
11,200 y luego en 2022 se alcanzó un
nuevo pico histórico con casi 11,900 es
decir el número de crímenes sexuales
incremento un 70 por en tan solo 5 años
luego otros delitos como los robos tanto
los comunes como los agravados por el
uso de la violencia han rebotado
bruscamente tras 5 años a la baja lo
hicieron especialmente tras el
levantamiento de las restricciones
sanitarias Pues bien esta es la
situación aclarados estos números
volvamos a la pregunta clave Qué
diantres es lo que está provocando este
repunte de la inseguridad pues mucho ojo
porque aquí viene lo más interesante de
todo
pecera grande peces
gordos queréis entender el problema del
crimen en Alemania Pues bien la oficina
de investigación criminal alemana ha
puesto el foco en el crimen organizado
en concreto según las autoridades
alemanas destacan cuatro grandes grupos
entre todos ellos En primer lugar
tenemos a la marca de la casa al Gran
talento local alemán del crimen las
bandas de motoristas ilegales en
Alemania existen cerca de 680
asociaciones de moteros con más de 7800
afiliados varias de ellas ya han sido
prohibidas en vari varios países
europeos y su especialidad delictiva
destaca por los micrel la distribución
de drogas la intimidación o los asaltos
pero en segundo lugar no podía faltar la
famosa mafia italiana de la que por
cierto subimos ya un vídeo en detalle en
visual economic Pues bien según reportes
oficiales la delincuencia organizada en
Alemania vinculada con La Mafia aumentó
un 12,5 por solo en 2022 en este caso
los mafiosos se dedican sobre todo a la
extorsión a la distribución de drogas y
el blanqueo de dinero ya sabéis todo lo
típico de películas como casino que por
cierto es un peliculón sea como como sea
en nuestra particular lista del crimen
aparece la delincuencia vinculada a
organizaciones rusas y euroasiática
entidades que básicamente son lideradas
y gestionadas desde los países de la
antigua órbita soviética pero finalmente
en el cuarto lugar tenemos a los clanes
sirios y libaneses cuya presencia se ha
incrementado bastante en los últimos
años pues bueno en general Las mayores
actividades delictivas que todos estos
grupos cometen se relacionan sobre todo
con el tráfico de drogas y el crimen
financiero pero amigos justo aquí es
donde llegamos al tema más espinoso de
todos la inmigración como seguramente
muchos ya sabéis Alemania ha sido uno de
los grandes partidarios de acoger
refugiados en Europa Así que seguramente
muchos ya estáis atando Cabos
inmigración refugiados efectivamente
delincuencia verdad pues esperad un
momento porque en este caso los datos no
parecen ir por ahí en su conjunto El
repunte de la violencia en Alemania
parece estar más ligado sobre todo a
grupos criminales Y sabéis qué de las
7200 personas detenidas en 2022 bajo la
sospecha de participar en organizaciones
criminales apenas 700 de ellas fueron
inmigrantes o dicho de otra forma que
solo uno de cada 10 detenidos por crimen
organizado son inmigrantes un porcentaje
que por cierto es muy inferior al peso
de la propia inmigración en Alemania y a
ver Es evidente que la llegada de
millones de personas de bajos recursos y
de países con culturas muy diferentes ha
influido en la comisión de delitos Más
allá del crimen organizado sin embargo
si hablamos del Gran repunte del crimen
actual Este ha sido promovido
principalmente por grupos criminales
grupos que están dirigidos por alemanes
o personas que ya llegaron al país hace
muchísimo tiempo pero es que son no es
todo otra característica importante es
que todas estas organizaciones han
tejido sus redes criminales a lo largo y
ancho del viejo continente tienen una
estrecha relación con sus colegas de
Holanda o de España lugares con acceso
marítimo susceptible al tráfico de
drogas y en ese sentido Holanda es uno
de los casos que más preocupa a las
autoridades alemanas la entienden como
una Macro puerta de entrada para el
tráfico de drogas y fuertes presiones
sobre el sistema judicial y como ya
imaginaréis tienen miedo a que esa
situación se extienda la propia
Alemania dorton stats ossen wurden oder
es gab fkam Die gefunden wurden Im
zusammenhang mit organis kriminalitet
amigos llegados a este punto queda claro
que los problemas de criminalidad a los
que se enfrenta Alemania son bastante
particulares no tienen tanto que ver con
la marginalidad económica la pobreza La
debilidad institucional o la emigración
que suelen ser los factores habituales
sino que el territorio teutón se está
convirtiendo en la base operativa de
varios peces gordos del crimen europeo
ahora bien Qué está haciendo el estado
para revertir esta situación porque sí
mucho diagnóstico mucha investigación
pero quién será capaz de ponerle el
cascabel al gato pues atención porque en
Berlín parece que hay más dudas que
certezas sobre Cómo enfrentar a este
[Aplausos]
[Música]
problema Un elefante en la
habitación de momento el diagnóstico de
las autoridades alemana sobre el repunte
criminal es por decirlo de alguna forma
bastante reservado en primer lugar los
portavoces de los cuerpos de seguridad
estiman que las estadísticas actuales
son digamos difíciles de comparar debido
a todos los cambios en los hábit
sociales que se han producido tras la
pandemia las cifras de casos registradas
en 2022 son comparables a las de 2019 El
último año antes de la pandemia esto
relativiza El Fuerte aumento con
respecto a 2021 Es probable que una de
las principales razones del aumento del
número de casos sea la supresión de las
restricciones impuestas por el
coronavirus y la consiguiente vuelta a
la normalidad de la vida pública más
libertad recuperada significa también
más oportunidades para que los
delincuentes cometan delitos el problema
pues que todo esto no parece Más que una
excusa porque a ver sí la vuelta a la
normalidad ha permitido que se vuelvan a
perpetrar muchos delitos pero eso
explicaría como mucho el regreso a los
niveles de 2019 Sin embargo la evolución
ha superado con creces el nivel previo a
la pandemia por tanto ese argumento pues
no parece una explicación razonable Y es
que si excluimos la tasa de homicidios
prácticamente todos los demás delitos
han crecido considerablemente respecto a
2019 y luego a eso tenemos que sumarle
que muchos delitos ya estaban en Franco
crecimiento desde 2018 así pues la
explicación del gobierno alemán pues no
parece sino una cortina de humo utilizar
la pandemia para dar patada para adante
e intentar camuflar una deriva que es
muy
negativa amigos Tal y como hemos visto
el mayor problema no tiene que ver con
la pandemia sino con la consolidación de
un montón de organizaciones criminales
en Alemania eso podría hacer que las
tasas de crimen no mejoren Próximamente
es decir que si no se hace nada el
actual brote podría haber llegado para
quedarse como ya hemos visto antes desde
el año 2020 operan al menos 100
organizaciones más de las que había
antes de la pandemia Y esto es lo que
explica un 2023 marcado por noticias
como estas Alemania e Italia reprimen
con redadas y detenciones a la mafia
italiana Austria en cauta un gran alijo
de armas en una redada contra moteros de
extrema derecha
absueltos 13 acusados en el juicio a
hells Angels y penas hasta 2 años para
otros 32 así que ya lo veis los cuerpos
de seguridad alemanes están Ni más ni
menos que ante su mayor desafío desde la
reunificación del país pero dicho esto
La pregunta es crees que estás
organizaciones criminales en Alemania
han llegado para quedarse cómo te
enfrentarías tú a este problema déjanos
tus impresiones en los comentarios y
habramos debate y ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like y suscribiros a
visual politic si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho ah importante recordad que
con el código politic acabado en K
podréis disfrutar de hasta 6 meses extra
totalmente gratis con susar el link como
siempre en la descripción Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima